Francis Suarez running for president my
dad taught me that you get to choose
your battles and I am choosing the
biggest one of my life I'm going to run
for president I'm going to run for your
children and mine let's give them the
future they deserve it's time to take
things into our own hands it's time to
get things started Francis Suarez mayor
of Miami he's a big lib he's compared to
where the GOP is right now he's just a
huge limb he posted a picture of himself
wearing a rainbow it looks like a beauty
pageant sash uh he tweets out quote June
is pride month what began as a statement
of defiance against outdated laws now
serves as a reminder in commemoration of
where this movement All Began over 50
years ago this movement that we're all
so proud to stand behind the LGBT
Elemento P movement as mayor of Miami I
stand with the lgbtq Positive community
and celebrating all month long this
wasn't 10 years ago by the way this was
two years ago he sent this tweet out
yeah I don't think so I don't I don't
think that's going to work